il avait peur de ne plus être aimé il ne
l'a jamais autant été depuis près de 30
ans souchon nous jouent l'air de rien la
mélodie du succès plus d'une sur scène
il semble de plus en plus amusé ça va ça
se passe bien ça se passe bien j'ai dû
ressort je saute petit peu puis savage
rebondit toujours le goût de la
simplicité dans son nouveau spectacle
touchant et entouré de photos
initialement le salaire sur
dans la sang elle m'a dit avant d'entrer
sur thème quelles sources des petits
trucs à quoi je pense à essayer de me
souvenir qui je suis les textes que je
vais dire ma braguette n'est pas ouvert
vous regardez vrai bon c'est vrai et
d'habitude et cour fermée de la dérision
même pour nous parler d'écologie dans
son nouvel album souchon demande pardon
à la nature que nous polluons en
regardant le temps passer
voix des métaux lourds et du sulfate
pardon un artiste qui semble s'être
débarrassé du trac
lui dément toujours dit ça au cinéma ou
sur l'acer m'a toujours dit vous faites
ça on dirait que vous sortiez de votre
salle à manger que vous arrivez les
doigts dans le nez mais en fait je suis
très tendu en fait si vous continuez à
le questionner souchon finira par
concéder modestement qu'avec le temps le
stress c'est un peu cas limités non mais
c'est à dire je commence à
jamais fragilité n'a autant rimer avec
popularité à 55 ans souchon n'est pas
près de s'arrêter
le public pas prêts à le quitter vingt
minutes après la fin de son spectacle
ils sont nombreux à rester là pour
chanter
donc c'est pour ça que carole et arrêts